yeah what made her step out of him being
like I'm calling the police because they
poisoned her with a drink dude like how
she spent all that money and she's all
like way dumb man right at what point do
you lose belief I can't afford to
believe you anymore
exactly this is too expensive to believe
[Music]
we have
another scam story oh more scams scams
are fun you love being scammed you go
scammy I love scamming dude what's a
scammy run what's this game allegedly
allegedly oh dude okay do I yeah go for
it go for it take a scam I don't even
know if I can get in trouble with it if
I do allegedly but you guys [ __ ]
figured out this never happened I
[ __ ] would get free food because I
would prank call restaurants
and I would act like so you want to know
this genius [ __ ] money to do a long
time ago like [ __ ] 20 years ago
allegedly allegedly allegedly what I
would do I would call and I'll use the
white voice and call Mexican restaurants
because they're the ones that don't want
trouble they don't want to be seen they
don't want the government nothing right
they're easy to get spooked on your own
people yes I know how to work on my
people [ __ ] and I always go over
there it's like hey how's it going hey
help you and like a taco shop or
whatever I could help you and I was just
like oh yeah I I actually stopped by
there for lunch earlier today and uh I
ordered a burrito and you guys gave me
like an enchilada or something and uh
you guys messed up my order right oh
okay uh sorry sorry to hear about that
it's okay I'm sorry like yeah uh so I'm
gonna I would love to have my lunch back
I had to go to my job I couldn't leave
you know my job so I had to like it was
during lunch time sorry and so I want my
food back and so they're like okay okay
uh we have your receipt I actually it's
a thing you guys uh didn't even give me
a receipt you guys forgot and then he
goes oh we forgot oh yeah I can't wait
for a gun okay uh okay come today uh uh
five o'clock we give you a burrito okay
and I was just like all right sounds
great I'll see you in a bit right but
the thing is I'm a white guy now right
so at five o'clock I call back hi um I'm
actually stuck at work my assistant my
son my stepson is gonna come in and he
actually he's uh you speak Spanish you
can talk to you a little bit more he's
gonna talk to you a little bit more
appreciate it thank you so much he's
gonna stop
upset pissed off that I'm there I don't
even want to be there I just like hey
get on there like
you told me to come pick up food or
something like I don't know what's going
on like I don't want to be there like
it's so embarrassing he wants me to pick
up food I'm like oh it's okay it's okay
I'm like all right thank you I'm sorry I
think he wants limes too and
but you'd have to go to like new
restaurants every single time because
you can't do it to the same one that's
right but there's a million Mexican
restaurants here but I would also change
hours oh I said like your new shits and
I'm like oh the morning shifts or night
shifts this guy's calling from a [ __ ]
car that's parked like this with a seat
down lower and then and then I figured
out two batboy figured out I figured out
that like uh some things that didn't
work because they'll be really like in
uh McDonald's they're very persistent
with the receipts so what do you do I
walk by there pick up any receipt on the
floor because people just drop receipts
pick it up go in there you guys [ __ ] up
my order here you go you don't need to
see the food as long as you have the
receipt they will have to give it to you
or sometimes that's a hustle receipt
they just see that you have a piece of
paper in your hand and they go that's
enough for me there you go you scoundrel
I love it I love it I love it I would
eat free food all the time time it was
like nothing for me was it was it rough
for you during that time or were you
just doing it for funsy you know what it
was it was the power
[Laughter]
the fact that I know I can do it the
fact that I would look at the table like
a drug dealer I receive a Taco Bell
Burger King McDonald's and I just looked
at it like
the city's mine
sorry I know you're gonna run into a
business owner like me yeah and I'll be
like not today not too late that's
[ __ ] not already good I jack those
millionaires [ __ ] those guys
well in this situation I went so [ __ ]
this this is a similar situation this
person's messing with his own people he
misses his own people his own people has
[ __ ] up isn't it Jesus [ __ ] [ __ ]
up I know this is uh this happens in
Australia right and why you gotta [ __ ]
with King Taco like that he's the homie
man said too much
so this happens in Australia Sydney
specifically and it's in the fortune
telling section oh I didn't see that one
coming a fortune teller Swindle is a mom
a single mom out of more than 22
thousand dollars in a scam that
basically wipes out her entire Lifesaver
[ __ ] but what was it what would make you
fall for such fortune-telling psychic
scams like what would make a single
mother be like I have to do this this
makes a burrito doesn't sound that bad
at all
this is good I need money from you
because a husband's coming your way and
I need to help you do that wait what do
you mean that's that's what she would
spend on I think or just be like yeah
let me predict your future for you and
you'll be set yeah break it down where's
the scam
basically this uh it's a little bit more
[ __ ] up than one scammer because it's
actually kind of like a mini racket okay
too many racket oh it's a whole
organization sidekick to tarot card
readers they got kangaroos in it and
koalas everybody's in it and got
Crocodile Dundee at everybody they're
buying it yup everybody and bye so a
couple of her colleagues all right a
couple colleagues coaxed her into is a
jumbo let's go ahead go ahead sorry I
went in
a couple of colleagues coaster into
going to a fortune telling shop down
this side and they were in on it this
little Lane right [ __ ] uh and uh the
second she goes in and sees the sidekick
psychics like the only thing I can see
at the moment is your kids your kids
lives are in danger right I don't get
them dude that's even yeah yeah that's
better than a husband one they say they
said her children had a bad Soul around
them and that psychics will come and
take the bad Soul away from them yeah so
the single mom who had recently been in
a car accident was told that she would
also soon be in another accident so
basically just grave danger all [ __ ]
heartstrings dude the hard part again
it's not just come from the cyclists
come from like her colleagues being like
yo you got some some Spirits you gotta
do
yeah they just created this entire Echo
chamber just to persuade her into doing
this so you know this lady sitting there
crying and stuff you know and they're
like we've come here for to pray for you
uh and they're like but it's gonna cost
you thirty dollars right thirty dollars
oh Dad that's expensive it's like dude
30 for a initial hand reading It's like
got to go in especially if everybody's
saying my kids are gonna die right and
then right after the handwriting all
[ __ ] stuff's getting real stuff's
getting worse you know we're gonna need
830 dollars to rid you of the curse that
has been plaguing your fans I'm sorry
that's a red flag right there like a 30
to 8 30 Jump that's a weird jump 30 is
just to like diagnose you know it's like
it's like a doctor Vision but getting
rid of the spirits ain't cheap that's
expensive business or they're like yo
800 bucks to save your children's lives
wow
you know I guess you could save one
guess you hate your kids thirty dollars
is like the the spirit diet diagnosis
that makes sense and then they're like
oh this one's gonna be a hard one we
found it yeah but I like how it's not
it's like a it's like an angel number
right it's like it's like off it's not a
flat 800. yeah yeah it can't be like
7.99 either it doesn't sound like a deal
right yeah it's just like this is a flat
standard rate everybody does this right
so she pays 800. I do not feel bad for
that person at all
I don't either the person who got
scammed it's like you're you're dumb
you're dumb you I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're dumb you have to say it though
really dude wait wait for the more
information this happens okay well I
mean no no I I like where you're going
but remember she said they're my
children and this man was telling me
their lives were in danger what was I to
do not continue not go to a psychic bruh
it's so easy I would tell him
describe my children yeah describe them
say something that they have that only
you what's their names start asking I'm
sorry but once you're telling me this
[ __ ] I'm like give me something to
spark something because because I know
you can just say anything give me
something that made me be like holy [ __ ]
only you would know that and me and oh
oh and if they can't do that then I'm
out I'm [ __ ] out and give me give me
my she did like no fact checking on The
credibility of it that's like it saying
I'm not gonna be Global just hearing
what I want like anybody can see me live
but that's why you don't go to Sidekicks
the people that go to Sidekicks they
don't fact check so would you say it's
easy money people that go to psychics
they're gullible already what people is
what you're saying dude I think I think
I might have gotten poached at a at a
grocery store one time because I was
like picking up crafties
um for uh for my company and
um I was like walking by and like this
lady comes to me she's like oh you know
your aura is really interesting oh here
we go oh really and I think I think at
this point too like I already just had
like a fresh like hair color dye on
there so I was like did she just like
pick up on me because I got colored hair
right and now she's like chilling in the
grocery store and she's like yeah like
there's something really interesting
going on I was like oh yeah tell me
about it she's like here's my card you
can reach to me and if you want a whole
like reading and I was like oh that's a
good lead you should flip it on her you
should out psychic her be like you know
what lady I kind of read you two and
your whole aura yes yes
exaggerate it and then just see what she
does I would have been like it was my
car for sure come to my business I would
have been like what a kawinky dink [ __ ]
because I felt the same thing about you
what that's what psychics
because I feel the same kind of energy
and honestly you are surrounded with so
much bad energy like and she would have
been like you think so like I
listen to
it right she's like I don't believe in
that [ __ ] yeah so after she handed me
her card I was like oh all right she's
like yeah come by you know like very
interesting you're so special I was like
you talk so you're like don't need it
no I didn't go but I saved it because I
was like this is a funny moment in my
group we should call him let's call him
yeah let's go let's all go please let's
all collectively say hey we called you
because you're in danger
I think you know just what if we go on
the assistant is the guy that she was
hiking with in [ __ ] Washington like
you're all in codes
okay but but y'all would have got it
away you guys want to go out of your way
to see a sidekick or no hell no I would
not I would not
um Bart's mom maybe how did it go from
800. yeah plus one is [ __ ] fortune
telling the type [ __ ] are you really
yeah Bart sports that's Joe oh nice
Asians look alike but yeah dude I
wouldn't so uh
she pays 830 bucks she gets this [ __ ]
spirit this dark Spirit lifted oh that's
so good but then the guy's like oh no
you need a master fortune teller to go
to your home though oh cause now we
gotta rid your house the whole further
black magic that might have been
haunting you that's bruja bro for this
they demanded 21 000 that's such a big
job it's a lot of money well it's a
whole house though it's like I don't
have this money so they're like no you
need to sell your car sell your jewelry
sell your possessions this is for your
children's life oh well if that's what
it takes to get the spirits out I I mean
I still don't know and then I believe it
you started with that claimed that she
needed
to have a drink
a type of drink for the spirits and
stuff and this drink made her unwell
and then while she was feeling unwell
she alleges that they convinced her to
transfer all of her money from her bank
account okay so that's it all right
that's too much what was this drink
called roofies
yes it's written here it's called
yeah dude I can't do that she reported
them to the police and stuff like that
some of it was returned on the spot
because he was like I'm calling the
police and he's like oh no don't call
the police he just here's some money
yeah
here's some money back you're an even
more danger yeah yeah you're bringing
more attention to the spirit but she's
still 12 000 out of pocket Jesus so okay
okay I'll give you half
yeah what made her snap out of him being
like I'm calling the police at that
point like because they poisoned her
with a drink dude it was Spirit she
spent all that money and she's all like
way dumb man right what point do you
lose beliefs right
I'm telling you I can't afford to
believe you anymore exactly
it's too expensive to believe I'm so
cheap that it's hard for me to like give
money you know what I mean you gotta
really give me somebody charged me for
something I'm like for what what am I
getting exactly
six chicken nuggets like you ordered
them like you know like you order six
chicken nuggets but are they chicken
really is it really chicken but he's so
cheap that he steals I'm
saving money by stealing yeah that's
dude I didn't spend money it's the best
way to [ __ ] being cheap stays in my
pocket I know dude I know it's terrible
I'm gonna look for receipts at
McDonald's now because yeah thanks for
the cool hack by the way yeah dude don't
use it it's like food tick tocks like
hey one way to get a free meal Tick Tock
hack oh yeah right I didn't go to jail
can you go to jail for that do we have a
fat Checker can you go to jail for that
not not in California
it's allegedly it never happened
laughs
[Music]